now let's move on and unpack notion the
organizational Powerhouse that redefines
how Architects manage their masterpieces
from inception to reval architecture is
no longer a solar act there are multiple
Consultants involved to make a drein
come true all of whom need to be
coordinated with notion you're the
Maestro of a dashboard that harmonizes
your project timelines Consultants
databases and your ever growing list of
to-do items but it doesn't stop there
imagine a world where you can draag Dr
and drop tasks set reminders that sync
to your calendar and share live updates
with your team notion doesn't just keep
track of your project it propels you for